the day began with a rush to the border
crossing into Greece the message from
Turkey was that it would be opened and
so they pushed forward
many young men at the front but many
women and children to and from all
across the Middle East
[Music]
behind them the Turkish border officials
watched on their government is
encouraging this to pressure Europe
the bangs are from shots fired by the
Greek police on the other side of the
frontier
[Applause]
tear gas was used to grease is already
overwhelmed by refugees who've been
there for years and the guards here have
orders to hold the line but this is the
effect of the gas 40 days among the
thousands here we met a father from Iran
yes Anu hi how are you you came here
because you thought the border was open
like many they need medical care but
can't afford to access it in Turkey over
each horizon they think it must be
better a natural human instinct and yet
wherever they move things seem to remain
terrible the afternoon brought a little
calm and time to sit with Yama Bashir
and his family I want a proper life and
a good future for my kids if I stay in
Turkey I will have no future I'll be
just a refugee once a translator for the
Americans in Afghanistan he's now here
in a field between Turkey and Greece
everybody has suffered a lot and again
we are suffering yeah it is again
a game played by world powers and
politicians one of them a Turkish
opposition party member was on the
border to see it for himself and he
understands why his president is doing
this the fact is that more than five
million refugees are kept in Turkey
since nineteen 2012 while how many vary
from UK UK how many refugees you have in
UK why we have to keep all these people
in the woods either side of the border
people waited thinking they get their
moment to cross the Turkish president
says 18,000 people have crossed into the
EU in the past 24 hours we've seen
nothing like that but he has focused
European leaders minds again and once
again there is misery on Europe's
borders mark stone Sky News in Turkey